Speaker 1: Let's go next to Manuel from Florida.
Welcome to the program, my friend.
Speaker 2: Hello, David.
Hello.
It has been a long time, but.
Yes.
Speak to you again.
Mm hmm.
Thank you.
Let's see.
I've been thinking about.
Sort of the direction of what is like popular
sentiment in America.
And it feels like the next generation is overwhelmingly
more liberal, more progressive.
I can't I can't cite that right now.
I don't have it off the top of my head.
No, but.
Speaker 1: You are right.
Generally speaking, each successively younger
generation is more progressive than the previous
four.
Now that continues to hold true.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
And but there's also like a lot of the things
that the conservative side of the spectrum
like hold on to are really old like traditions.
Right?
They go back a long time.
Yes.
So you'll always have that that in some capacity,
you know, whether it's smaller, big on that
side of the spectrum.
But do you think they would ever be.
I don't know.
Like I don't see it ever going away.
But do you think it'll come back?
Like, do you think, for example, of Christian
nationalism then it'll truly grow to be popular?
Or will it always?
They're kind of this smaller niche.
Speaker 1: I don't think any prediction I
could make about that would be worth a penny.
I mean, really, humans are so terrible at
making these types of predictions.
And this is why when Trump was using the line
during his 2012, I think it was in 2020, he
would say, we will never be a socialist country.
Maybe we will.
I don't know.
I mean, it doesn't seem to be going in that
direction right now.
But how can we say the U.S. will never be
a socialist country, 500 years, a thousand
years if the U.S. is still around?
Maybe it will be a socialist country.
That being said, right now there's no socialists
in power, so it's not going to happen any
time soon.
So I would be very hesitant to make any.
Maybe Christian nationalism will maybe we
will be a fully legal Christian theocracy
at some point in time.
I don't know.
I would hesitate to make any of these never
predictions.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
No, I feel that I mean, this is kind of a
what about ism?
And I was just thinking about it because you
see, a lot of people say that Christian nationalism
is a threat.
So I wonder, like, is it a threat in so far
as it could become popular or is it just a
threat insofar as this small group of people
can be very dangerous?
Speaker 1: I think it depends on who you ask
and exactly where and what year it is.
But I think it's fair to say that Christian
nationalism is a threat in the sense that
it threatens the America that the founding
fathers created.
That's it's a threat in that sense.
And then is it a practical and imminent threat?
Well, there is a group that, if they took
power, would make Christian theocracy a reality.
Right now, they thankfully don't have that
power, but they are certainly a threat in
that they want more power.
So it's just about better defining what we
mean by threat, if that makes sense.
Speaker 2: No.
Yeah, that does make sense.
Yeah.
I just want to hear what your thoughts were
on that to appreciate it again.
Speaker 1: Well, I appreciate the call very
much.
Things are okay in Florida.
Speaker 2: Oh, the things are great.
The weather's like right now, we're looking
at like 70 degree weather.
It's like, I'm in California.
So, yeah, well.
Speaker 1: I'm hoping to get down soon and
reschedule this appearance with Patrick, Bette,
David that I was supposed to do.
And yeah, before you know it, I might be back
in Florida.
Speaker 2: Okay.
Awesome.
Yeah.
I have a Cuban sandwich right here.
Have you want a Cuban sandwich?
Speaker 1: Cuban.
Oh, right.
Yeah.
Well, we'll talk about that.
Let's talk about the pork later.
All right.
Okay, Manuel, thank you very much for the
call.
Appreciate it.
That does it for today.
We're done for the day with live calls.
Appreciate everyone I was able to speak to.
And we will take live calls again.